في ركاب طائره روسيه عاشوكابوس الحقيقه
ولحظات من الرعب ما بينحسوا عليها ابدا
يمكن الواحد لو كان مكانهم انا كان حرفيا
يمكن متت من الخوف بصراحه الرعب اللي صار
هو انه طياره صغيره من طراز اي ان 26 باب
هالخلفه انفتح وهم في محلقين في الجو
الطياره طبعا تعرضت لمشكله فنيه
فتح الباب واحد من الركاب مش عارفه بصراحه
كيف سيطر اداري يسيطر على اعصابه على حاله
وصور ووثق اللي صار بالضبط
الله يعينهم على اللحظات الصعبه انا ما
باعرف لو انا كنت مكانهم شو كان ممكن
اعمله الباب فتح على كل حال وبلشت اغراض
الركاب بتطير هذا غير طبعا البرد يعني
اصلا الجو تخيلوا على ارتفاع عالي بيكون
تحت الصفر فتخيلوا انه هن مقلعين من منطقه
سايبيريا للحراره فيها على الارض مش بالجو
يمكن ناقص 44 او همم 44 تحت الصفر فكيف
تخيلوا في الجو عموما لحسن الحظ الطاقه في
الطياره طبيعي
ولفت ورجعت وهبطت بسلام والركاب ال 25
الحمدللهم شيء طياره مثل ما قلنا هي طياره
روسيه فمين اللي حب يستغل الموقف وما
يمرقها اوكراني طبعا مستشار لوزير الشؤون
الداخليه الاكرانيا المسؤول نشر الفيديو
حكى اللي صار وعلق بالاخر وكتب هل نغير
اسم الرولات الروسي ونس الطائره الروسيه
طبعا للي ما بيعرف الرولات الروسي هي لعبه
حظ مميته معروفه من قروره وهي ببساطه انه
ينحط طلقه واحده في
الفرد او في بيت الطلقات باي فرد وبالتالي
بعد هيك بينطخ على شخص تطلع الطلقه ما
بتطلع الطلقه عاد هو وحظه